salut que vous me connaissiez depuis une
seconde un mois ou dix ans vous savez
sûrement que mon domaine de prédilection
ce qui me passionne plus dans le cerveau
c'est notre mémoire on aurait tous dans
le cerveau une capacité de stockage
d'environ 2,5 pétaoctets de données
c'est l'équivalent de plus d'un million
de films en full hd on va voir comment
ce pouvoir fonctionne dans notre cerveau
parce que la mémoire c'est à la fois
très personnel et en même temps c'est
notre plus gros points communs à vous à
moi toute l'humanité qui n'a jamais
retenu des choses qui semblent inutiles
ou au contraire qui n'a jamais eu
l'impression d'avoir oublié des choses
voire des années entières de sa vie moi
ça me l'a fait vous connaissez sûrement
les intervenants de la vidéo qui vont
témoigner aujourd'hui à laury thilleman
qui est aux tris et présentatrice à la
télévision il ya un 'mix' m créateurs de
contenus sur internet mais qui dirige
aussi plusieurs entreprises annoncent
incalculable de projets gili alias 2
février qui produit également du contenu
sur internet et qui a vu sa vie basculer
le jour où 40 % de son corps a été brûlé
par les flammes michel cymes médecin
connu pour ses émissions de télé hauteur
de la santé du cerveau ma nombril
créatrice de vidéo parlant de l'histoire
avec un grand h et enfin mike d'inca
chanteur auteur et co fondateur du
groupe sinsemilia que vous connaissez
entre autres pour la chanson tout le
bonheur du monde tout le bonheur du
monde parce que oui vous les connaissez
dans leur domaine de prédilection la
bouse excellent mais vous les connaissez
bien moins dense qu'il ya de plus intime
dans leur vie leur mémoire leurs
souvenirs leurs oublis la mémoire c'est
un sujet bien plus vaste est bien plus
complexe qu'il n'y paraît vous ne savez
peut-être pas mais je mémoire un petit
peu différente de la norme et ça m'a
mené dès l'enfance à m'intéresser à ce
sujet au point que l'un de mes premiers
métiers c'était de faire des conférences
sur les méthodes de mémorisation cette
vidéo devrait mettre votre cerveau en
ébullition je m'appelle fabien olicard
je suis passionné par le cerveau et
particulièrement par la mémoire est
aujourd'hui sort mon sixième livre qui
parle de ce pouvoir incroyable que nous
possédons tous donc pour celles et ceux
que ça intéresse je vous en parlerai à
la toute fin de la vidéo pour le moment
direction des 70 milliards de neurones
et les 10 puissance 15 synapses qui
peuplent notre cerveau pour former nos
souvenirs et donc nos pensées
[Musique]
comme pour les deux premières vidéos
similaires sur l'échec et sur la passion
j'ai commencé par demander à mes invités
ce que le révoquer le mot mémoire
à moi tout de suite s'il ya souvenirs et
j'ai pas pourquoi j'ai tendance à penser
bons souvenirs et puis après mémoire il
ya ça peut aussi être il ya une notion
de travail l'année marque pour moi c'est
une accumulation de
souvenirs du passé qui restent stockées
dans un coin du cerveau et qui refont
surface à des moments où tu t'y attends
pas du tout où des fois des moments
opportuns pour te faire te rappeler des
choses dont tu as besoin de te rappeler
pour avancer le mot mémoire m'évoque
beaucoup de souffrance parce que quand
on fait des études de médecine bien
évidemment il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à apprendre par coeur il a memoir
moi j'ai toujours eu un énorme problème
avec alors j'ai trouver des subterfuges
et trouver des des moyens de mémoriser
la mémoire c'est ce qui est subjectif
donc c'est des témoins c'est aussi bien
individuellement ton souvenir à toi à
chaque témoin d'un événement pipeline
histoire etc t comment on a vécu un truc
on le transmet on leur apporte c'est
forcément subjectif puisque c'est un
point de vue la mémoire aussi c'est ce
qui fait que l'instant présent a du sens
ce que tu te réfères forcément à une
multitude d'éléments du passé pour que
l'instant présent et du sens mémoire je
pense aux cours je pense à mes leçons je
pense à l'école je pense à tout ça et
j'étais toujours très complexée quand
j'étais petit de ne pas intégrer mais
court quand je les lisais mais quand je
les écoutais alors j'ai la particularité
et je m'en suis rendu compte qu'il ya
pas longtemps en plus que j'avais une
mémoire auditive et non visuelles c'est
vraiment passionnant on découvre que
chaque personne a un rapport précis
intime à sa mémoire plusieurs des
invités comme michel ou loris pense
avoir une mémoire visuelle ou une
mémoire auditive ou alors une mémoire
kinesthésique on appelle ça le bac
en réalité les aires visuelles auditives
et nice tesic du cerveau sont reliées
entre elles elle communique en
permanence énormément ensemble cette
mémoire se disant dominante c'est un
neuro mythe qui n'a jamais été démontrée
par une recherche scientifique
d'ailleurs en 2006 a décrit un prix de
5000 $ qui récompensera la personne qui
démontrerait l'existence de la mémoire
dominante et le prix n'a toujours pas
été attribués alors pourquoi on a tant
l'impression que ça existe quand même
que nous apprenons mieux en écoutant ou
en voyant quelque chose pourquoi ça
marche même sur moi j'ai l'impression
d'avoir une mémoire plus tôt visuel en
réalité c'est la mise en oeuvre du biais
de confirmation qui fait que nous
portons notre attention sur les
expériences qui confirment l'efficacité
de ce que nous croyons être notre
mémoire dominante du coup on retient que
ça dont qu'on a l'impression que ça
existe passons donc au delà de notre
manière d'apprendre et voyons si nous
stockons les mêmes souvenirs dans nos
neurones ou pas la mémoire c'est du
stockage sais-tu stockage c'est le mot
c'est un disque dur mais c'est pas le
processeur central qui choisit quelles
données vont remonter tu vois c'est un
processeur a5 c'est un disque dur un peu
random ça remonte un peu comme ça veut
mémoire c'est subjectif ça veut pas
forcément dire que c'est mal mais c'est
juste c'est une sélection précise de
kehl 2 pourquoi on décide de se rappeler
de ça ou non est aussi forcément c'est
un point de vue c'est ce qu'il en reste
ou pas et l'histoire elle essaye de
reprendre ses mémoires justement les
traces toutes les sources historiques
qui peut y avoir pour en tirer les
grandes lignes et en essayant le plus
possible de ne pas avoir un point de vue
justement comment un organe le cerveau
en l'occurrence d'une précision extrême
pourrait avoir un fonctionnement
aléatoire on a pourtant souvent cette
impression de ne pas choisir ce dont
nous allons nous souvenir alors qu'est
ce qui fait vraiment la différence d'une
personne à l'autre et qu'est-ce qui
choisit ce dont nous allons nous
souvenir ou pas je me rappelle plus de
mon primaire que de mon collège j'ai
vraiment l'impression que ma mémoire a
fait une sélection dans le passé vas-y
ces trois quatre années là on les garde
ses trois quatre années la face à des
cages ça prend de la place a vraiment
fait des choix certes indépendant de ma
volonté d'autres complètement dépendant
de ma volonté et ça je pense que ça
vient du fait que ma mémoire est
vraiment saturé je vais avoir tendance à
me souvenir de plein de petits détails
mais c'est aussi parce que je suis
quelqu'un très attentive donc des fois
ça peut être trop court pour faire des
cadeaux en fait parce que tu te souviens
d'un truc que la personne at a dit
qu'elle voulait ya très longtemps et du
coup tu te souviennes ça et tu dis ok
bah ça ça peut être ça fait genre une
cithare idée je suis tdh dont tous de
l'attention et d'hyperactivité ce qui
fait que dans tout de la tension il ya
attention et que pour mémoriser il faut
d'attention et que pour moi c'est très
compliqué des textes que je n'avais pas
écrit où je reprenais des textes des
amis que vraie galère vraie galère à
apprendre un texte tout simple mais qui
n'est pas de moi à tel point que j'ai un
souvenir d'un concert gravité par
danakil pour venir chanter 1 3 minutes
avant je suis en panique comme ça je
connais pas mon texte n'est pas mon
texte g8 phrase tant que c'est les miens
aucun souci j'allais vraiment capable
d'emmagasiner un maximum d'informations
par exemple en culture générale je vais
pouvoir emmagasiné énormément
d'informations au quotidien sans même
m'en apercevoir
à condition que ça mais intéressé si ça
va pas intéresser poubelle c'est ça qui
était par exemple je me souviens d'un
tournage du vortex la chaîne dirt et
donc on prend le métro et on discute
d'un truc ensuite on arrive sur les
lieux du tournage le soir on mange et on
rediscute de ce truc et je redis tous
les mêmes trucs pareils et léa et
patrick hivon bah oui on en a parlé tout
à l'heure dans le métro et je ne m'en
souviens pas mais cela correspondait à
un moment où j'avais eu des nouvelles
très dur la veille et l'avant veille et
tout donc j'étais
il ya un point commun dans tous ces
témoignages c'est l'attention notre
cerveau pour choisir ce qu'il veut pas
stocker doit se fier à un critère
objectif et ce critère c'est vous et du
coup c'est votre attention dans
l'exemple de manon elle avait reçu une
très mauvaise nouvelle la veille on peut
facilement estimé que son intention
n'était donc pas porté sur sa journée de
travail mais plutôt sur la nouvelle
qu'elle avait reçus si vous ne prenez
aucune attention à une chose alors votre
cerveau se dit que c'est pas très
intéressante dépenser d'énergie pour
stocker ce souvenir dans le temps par
exemple si vous n'avez pas vous sont vos
clés chez vous c'est parce que vous avez
prêté aucune attention au moment où vous
les avez posé quelque part en rentrant
chez vous il suffirait alors d'être un
tout petit peu plus ancré dans le moment
présent pour être plus attentifs et donc
pour mieux souvenu ya des périodes de ma
vie qui sont très précises souvent des
moments en fait tout jeu à ce moment là
je savais que je ne voulais pas oublier
cette période là par exemple ça peut
être en lien avec un lieu une maison ou
un membre de ma famille ou même mon
chien où je sais que ça va pas durer
pour x raisons et donc du coup à
l'époque je suis concentré à ne pas
oublier et ça fonctionne genre je me
rappelle de moments où je me suis dit ce
maxime n'oublie jamais ça et ça fait
très longtemps et ça a vraiment marché
quoi comme si j'avais pris une photo
mentale de certains moments et quand je
n'ai pas pris la peine de prendre cette
photo mentale rappelle pas du tout un
très bel exemple de maxime qui montre
que nous connaissons cette vérité au
fond nous si nous voulons nous souvenir
de quelque chose il faut avant tout le
décider après ce que c'est suffisant
j'ai demandé à mes invités de me
dévoiler leurs plus vieux souvenirs
datant sûrement d'une époque où il
décidez pas vraiment consciemment de
portée de la tension pas sur quelque
chose la plus vieille chose dont je me
souvienne c'est quand j'étais en home
d'enfants alors je devais avoir
peut-être six sept huit ans et où on
obliger à aller aux toilettes pour faire
caca à une heure très précises ça m'a
beaucoup traumatisé depuis j'y vais tous
les jours à la même heure
la maternelle reste un souvenir très
marqué je me rappelle vraiment de mes
années maternelle en fait est la
première à l'aide d'internet il me
semble que c'est un truc où je suis
vraiment enfants donc tout petit et que
ma soeur aînée ya pas très longtemps
donc je dois voir trois ans un truc
comme ça et je me souviens de papa ou de
maman je sais plus lequel qui me propose
de manger chez c'est même plus quelle
partie de l'oeuvre le jeune de l'oeuvre
pour lui donner le blanc elle ou
linverse peut-être et je crois que c'est
mon plus vieux souvenir le mois qui
pleure et d'une la rentrée scolaire moi
qui pleure en maternelle et une petite
fille qui va me consoler remet donc tout
va bien tout va bien aller je crois que
c'est ça des plus vieux souvenir une
balade
on partait soit en camping car avec mes
parents et je devais avoir
5 6 ans je vais dire et je me sois
qu'avec mes parents c'était batailler
dans le dans l'herbe je sais pas où
j'étais très énervé contre ma maman et
on se bataillaient je crois qu'on se
faisait même témoin d'eric je vous ai
mangé de l'herbe et elle me faisait
manger de l'herbe mon père né nous
séparer mais c'était un moment à la fois
hilarant je me sens que j'étais très
remonté et que et que voilà je me
chamaillaient un peu avec ma maman mon
plus vieux souvenirs donc j'habitais à
lyon avec mes parents et on part se
promener pour faire visiter lyon à ma
grand mère qui n'est pas du tout de la
et du coup on prend le funiculaire donc
le petit train qui montrent une butte
quoi en gros une colline quoi et on
prend le funiculaire et le funiculaire
tombe en panne et les portes du
funiculaire s'ouvre en plein milieu
d'une sorte de tunnel dans le noir et ma
grand mère qui ne connaît pas lyon du
tout se dit on est arrivé alors qu'on
n'est pas arrivé on est dans un tunnel
dans le noir c'est pas un lieu de
promenade adéquat elle sort des portes
se referment et moi je vois donc ma
grand-mère disparaître dans la pénombre
est on est on part en fait on continue
nous notre route quoi donc en fait mon
premier souvenir c'est un traumatisme
j'avais deux ans quel est le point
commun tous ces souvenirs qu'ils nous
ont raconté ce sont les émotions dans
quasiment chacune de ces anecdotes il y
a une ou des émotions fortes qu'elles
soient positives ou négatives d'ailleurs
la force de ses émotions est décuplée
par le fait qu'il s'agit souvent de
première fois dans leur vie dans le
cerveau c'est l'hippocampe qui va
décider dans quelle mémoire il va
stocker les nouvelles informations il va
pour ça se référer à la raison et donc à
la tension mais aussi à la milk dalle
qui va donner une valeur émotionnelle
positive ou négative au souvenir c'est
vraiment comme dans vice versa
évidemment plus cette valeur
émotionnelle est forte plus le souvenir
sera précis comme par exemple les
abonnés que qui me reconnaissent dans la
rue et qui m'ont déjà vu lors d'un
événement précédent il ya quatre ans
forcément bon pour eux c'est ils ont vu
que moi alors que moi j'ai vu des
centaines de personnes donc quand c'est
un peut potentiellement dexant pour la
personne que moi je me rappelle pas
parce que le gars va me dire oui mais si
j'étais en poulet ouais mais sur les
sept dernières années de ma vie j'en ai
vu des gars en poule r
comme xm parle de ses abonnés déguisé en
poulet ça se munir forte pour l'abonné
parce qu'il est déguisé peut-être pour
la première fois en poule et c'est la
première fois qu'il rencontre mxm mais
pourra mixer m c'est une forme de
routine très étrange de dire ça mais en
tout cas comme c'est une routine pas
d'attention particulière pas d'émotion
particulière donc pas de souvenirs
particuliers ouais je pense que que que
tous les souvenirs que je me forge et
ceux qui sont le plus ancré en moi sont
liées à des fortes d'émotion ou des reer
ou des pleurs ou de la tristesse ou de
la joie ou de la colère j'ai aussi eu
des trous de mémoire à des moments où ça
allait très mal fin 2018 2019 c'est une
année très très dur à cause
d'un épuisement dans une relation
toxique notamment et de la fin de vie de
la mère peu de temps après on s'est pris
deux qu'ovide qu'on est resté un peu
enfermé et ensuite quand on a recommencé
à sortir et à plein de gens voient la
cour en 2020 2021 que j'avais pas vu
puis l'année 2019 et qui misait pas tu
te souviens à la fois qu'on s'est vus
c'était l'anniversaire de machins et
blabla et tout est en fait moi je me
suis rendu compte que cette année
j'avais presque passer quoi que les
noeuds de mes problèmes traumatisant
cela a par contre ils sont très claires
mais toute la vie qui a eu autour elle a
disparu
[Musique]
la mémoire elle fonctionne en trois
temps l'encodage de l'information le
stockage de l'information la
récupération de l'information par une
trace mnésique dans le cerveau qui va se
dissoudre dans le temps ou alors se
renforcer quand on révise ou qu'on fait
appel à ses souvenirs on avait ça la
courbe de l'oubli en parlant d'oubli est
ce que mes invités pense avoir une bonne
ou une mauvaise mémoire les chiffres
sans problème le boulot sans problème
monsieur vient de vieux numéros de
téléphone que j'ai pas utilisé depuis 40
ans qui d'ailleurs doivent plus exister
comme numéro de téléphone et il ya des
trucs ou non au contraire c'est
catastrophique vous voit de la mémoire
donc c'est très sélectif chez moi tout
ce qui est pour moi mais est sans
importance même si après ça des
conséquences parce qu'après je perds une
heure à chercher mes clés et ses
mémoires à très court terme excellente
j'ai une mémoire à court terme
excellente c'est ce qui m'a permis
d'avoir tous mes diplômes je peux
réviser des quantités d'informations
importantes pour les retranscrire à 24
48 heures après et dans une semaine je
sais plus par contre si je remette
dedans pour x raisons maintenant j'ai
loupé un examen en cours à l'époque
quand j'étais ans d'études et ou pas
forcément si je me remette dedans c'est
plus facile quoi elle n'a pas
complètement supprimé tout mais si on me
demande comme ça les informations je
vais pas pouvoir la sortir j'oublie
essentiellement beaucoup de choses que
les gens m'ont dit où on me raconte une
anecdote et j'oublie même si du coup
pour les gens ça peut faire un peu peur
parce qu'une personne qui t'a raconté
une anecdote droit dans les yeux et tu
dis je me rappelle pas alors que ça fait
peut-être un mois la personne doit pas
forcément pour prendre une énorme
mémoire visuelle c'est ce qui m'a permis
je pense d'avoir mon bac dans mon métier
quand on fait par exemple un emplacement
produit quand on va travailler avec une
marque on va souvent avoir un brief eh
ben je sais qu'en fait j'ai besoin de
lire ce brief une fois pour pouvoir me
souvenir des éléments clés et ce qui est
assez dingue c'est que vraiment quand je
parle je je revois enfin genre je vais
parler et je revois le brief à côté de
moi avec les mots en fête qui qui
apparaissent comme ça et ça me faisait
exactement ça au bac me rappelais
vraiment mes fiches à l'oral tout ce que
j'avais écrit là sur le papier ça les
papiers à carreaux moi j'ai une mémoire
compte 10 de travail saisir très courte
mémoire ul j'ai une mémoire qui ne
s'ajuste pas dit photographique c'est à
dire que je il faut vraiment que je me
concentre sur ce que je dois apprendre
avec des couleurs des petits dessins et
c'est comme ça que j'ai réussi
finalement à faire mes études de
médecine heureusement que les stabilos
existe la plus éclatée de mémoire c'est
la mémoire moyen terme quoi c'est à dire
il y a quelques mois il ya quelques
années en fait depuis que je suis sur
you tube ma mémoire à moyen terme allait
dégueulasse je ne sais plus qui sait que
j'ai croisés qui sait que j'ai vu déjà
de base je ne suis pas du tout
physionomiste je ne sais plus en quelle
année était quel événement alors que
c'était des années importantes et des
événements importants je mélange tout
parce que tout a été trop saturé je
pense vraiment je me rappelle de tout
globalement en fait mais je sais plus
lol la chronologie n'a plus aucun sens
et ouais je peut avaler beaucoup de
trucs pour un court terme et où j'ai été
une bête à concours entre guillemets tu
vois genre j'ai fait 10e concours de
prof des écoles après j'ai fait mon ma
licence et easy mais sur du court tout
court terme comme le temps qu'il faut
pour l'examen machin est ensuite à brême
c'est à dire que donc déjà gmac est
éclatée de plains beaucoup trop de trucs
quittera donc je passe mon temps à
oublier les trucs qui sont dans sa wii
fait un sang a pas besoin ça on pourra
vérifier dans l'agenda plus tard et tout
par contre je me souvenir hyper bien de
d'éléments importants qui ont marqué ma
vie plutôt ces choses là je me souviens
que j'étais avec machin habillée comme
ça on s'est dit ça à tel endroit et nana
ces trucs là les les souvenirs de vie
mais jusqu'à pas trop trop loin dans le
temps non plus on peut pas vraiment dire
qui est une mémoire à moyen terme c'est
pas vrai il ya les mémoires à court
terme essentiellement la mémoire de
travail qui va retenir peu de temps
environ cette information en simultané
et les mémoires à long terme telles que
la mémoire procédurale la mémoire
sémantique la mémoire épisodique qui
sont la mémoire du corps des données des
souvenirs mais il en existe d'autres
comme la mémoire perceptive on a un
aspirateur en fait à la maison sans fil
et en fait j'ai souvent mes longs
cheveux blonds qui se coince dans le
rouleau de l'aspirateur et un jour il y
avait trop de cheveux et palais les
enlever donc moi j'ai sorti ce boulot et
je voulais couper les cheveux et mon
chéri tout à fait spontanément me dit
non mais vas-y en fait ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va brûler enfin en tanzanie
je bouge pas un briquet je brûle les
cheveux et en fait l'odeur du cheveux
brûlés alors que c'est quand même dingue
parce que moi je me rappelle de mon
accident mais je me rappelle pas de
l'odeur en fête du feu ou de quoi que ce
soit et bah instantanément il a mis le
feu aux cheveux sur la brosse et en fait
et j'ai pas pu contrôler c'est à dire
que j'ai senti et les larmes elles ont
coulé directement comme si voilà c'était
vraiment stocker quelque part j'ai
vraiment fait ce trou noir avec le coma
artificiel des souvenirs qui sont censés
être en off est en fait l'olfactif me
fait me rappeler de certaines choses
dont je devrais peut-être pas me
rappeler un peu comme si l'on m'avait
privé d'autres sens je ne voyais pas je
pouvais pas toucher peut-être c'est ça
qui peut créer certains souvenirs et en
fait je me dis que en fait celle
olfactif la mémoire olfactive qui a pris
le dessus sur tout ça et je m'en rends
vraiment compte quotidiennement et je
connais un nombre incalculable de
musique parker 300-400 musique vraiment
par claire sur le bout des doigts et ça
me revient vraiment je pense que c'est
peut-être auditifs en fait parce que je
n'ai jamais vu j'ai jamais vu les
paroles écrites dont je pense que c'est
une bonne mémoire auditive c'est ce que
l'on appelle la madeleine de proust une
odeur une musique ça peut déclencher la
remontée d'un souvenir qui était
déconnectée du système en gros vous
savez pas de vous vous en souveniez mais
il existait encore des connexions avec
vos sens la mémoire c'est un petit peu
comme une pelote de laine ou si vous
tirez sur le bon fil ensuite il ya tout
qui revient tout souvenir s'enchaînent
du coup je me suis posé la question est
ce que mes intervenants ont des craintes
concernant leur mémoire ou leur oubli de
souvenirs ça fait flipper je trouve la
capacité de nos sociétés a est passé de
la mémoire ou à oublier des choses sur
lequel on devrait s'appuyer qui devrait
nous aider à construire ou à parfaire
pas refaire les mêmes erreurs enfin oui
il ya un truc autour de la de la mémoire
commune qui petit à petit s'est pas à
souhait où est effacée par certains qui
fait flipper alors déjà j'ai peur de
perdre ma mémoire très simplement comme
beaucoup beaucoup de gens en
vieillissant je pense que ça fait partie
des des choses qui font le plus peur
quoi ces deux plus se souvenir de ses
proches les gens que tu as aimé dans ta
vie les gens qui t'ont aimé les lieux
aussi je pense vraiment s'il pense que
c'est important les lieux là où tu as
grandi dans quelle fille tuée mais peur
d'oublier des souvenirs aussi vraiment
je me rends compte que quand je pense à
des souvenirs du coup d'enfance il va me
revenir et je me dis tiens c'est marrant
il ya cinq ans dix ans je me rappelais
très bien et là j'aurais pu l'oublier
heureusement que j'en suis rappelé parce
que j'aurais pu l'oublier ça en fait je
suis sûr qu'à plein souvenirs qui sont
ça y est définitivement perdu gros j'ai
perdu le dvd bas des fois tu vois des
choses ou des photos et tu dis est ce
que je me souviendrai de ce souvenir là
où je sais juste parce que je les
voulais revu récemment oui j'ai jamais
été très physionomiste oui j'ai toujours
eu du mal à mémoriser parce que l'on
trouve de la tension mais en
vieillissant ces mêmes symptômes
prennent de l'importance parce qu'on se
dit oulala si ça se trouve c'est le
cerveau qui commencent à partir en
couille en plus moi j'ai l'angoissent de
d'oublier les trucs importants
maintenant ma mère elle est décédée donc
le rapport à ce qu'elle m'a raconté ces
choses là c'est
important quand ça comptait tous plus
jeune elle m'a raconté plein de fois ces
trucs-là ou même encore récemment et m'a
raconté les histoires de famille les
trucs comme ça sur le moment je les
écoute en faisant c'est important il
faut que je me rappelle et après je
mélange un peu jeu confuses et bref mon
rapport à ça il est ambigu parce que
c'est extrêmement précieux et en même
temps ça m'échappe ça m'échappe à des
endroits où je voudrais bien que ça
m'échappe et inversement savez chat pas
à d'autres émetteurs c'est qu'en fait ma
mémoire me sacré tour par rapport à par
rapport à montereau main en fait j'ai un
peu peur des fois ne pas pouvoir
contrôler certaines de mes réactions
j'ai peur que que ça
que ça vienne dans un moment où c'est
pas censé venir pense que ma mémoire et
mes souvenirs ont joué deux sacrés touré
ont développé en fait des phobies
inexistante à la base chez moi ma
mémoire se souvient de ce qui s'est
passé dans le coma artificiel le feu
puisse la chaleur cet enfermement et
c'est en fait ça a développé en moins
une claustrophobie par exemple en été
quand je dors s'il fait trop chaud et
que je suis tout le monde rame en fait
je vais vite faire une crise d'angoissé
ou par exemple quand je suis dans mon
lit et que j'ai chaud je me revois en
fait dans le lit de l'hôpital et ça ça
me fait peur parce que voilà c'est des
choses que je peux pas contrôler je
contrôle beaucoup de choses dans ma vie
voici donc les deux grandes peurs de mes
invités la peur de perdre ce bien si
précieux simic si personnelle que sont
les souvenirs il a peur également de ne
pas contrôler la remontée de certains
souvenirs d'ailleurs je me pose une
question comment est ce qu'on oublie
vraiment des choses il n'y a pas si
longtemps je parlais avec avec mon ami
qui était avec moi le jour de l'accident
et elle m'a rappelé en fait à un moment
parce qu'il s'est passé le jour de mon
accident que moi j'avais complètement
occulté en fait on en parlait donc le
fait qu'elle m'en parlent se souvenir a
refait surface et c'est comme s'ils se
souvenir bah du coup il m'appartenait
pas et que mon ami en en parlant elle
avait elle avait mis sans le vouloir
dans un coin de ma tête il ya des choses
que mon cerveau a préféré oublier je
pense pour me protéger et que la mémoire
en fait n'oublie pas et fait ressurgir
des fois donc c'est
tout d'abord il ya des traumas comme ce
que je lis a vécu le stress post
traumatique c'est une erreur d'encodage
du cerveau mal encoder le souvenir est
mal stockés et au lieu d'être digérés
comme ils devraient l'être il reste
coincé dans le présent la manière de
traiter ça aujourd'hui c'est souvent de
rappeler le souvenir pour en baisser la
charge émotionnelle à l'aide de
techniques ou parfois l'aide de
médicaments pour transformer le souvenir
traumatique en simple souvenir lee a
également les choses que l'on n'oublie
réellement dans le temps c'est souvent
dû un encodage trop léger et le fait de
ne pas avoir rappelé cette information
pendant des années et il ya bien sûr les
maladies neurodégénératives comme
alzheimer ou la mémoire épisodique s'en
mêle complètement alors est-ce qu'on
doit s'inquiéter de ne pas tout retenir
est-ce qu'on peut aider notre cerveau
pour mieux le faire peur que ouais peur
que ce muscle soit plus aussi efficace
qu'avant et sidya un peu mou c'est comme
un muscle
mal entretenues quoi ça devient
handicapant au fur et à mesure je pense
que j'ai un métier qui est pas hyper
favorable pour la mémoire ce que c'est
un récit très dans l'instant et dans le
court terme et en fait tous mes projets
sont à deux ou trois semaines c'est très
court j'ai j'entretiens pas beaucoup ma
mémoire
moyen et long terme quoi alors déjà la
mémoire ou cerveau ça n'est pas un
muscle c'est un organe et c'est surtout
le seul organe qui ne s'use que lorsque
l'on ne s'en sert pas
[Musique]
la meilleure façon de prendre soin de
notre cerveau et notre mémoire c'est de
stimuler sa richesse cognitive alors
comment on fait bien on sort on discute
on s'intéresse au monde qui nous entoure
la meilleure manière de prendre soin de
son cerveau c'est de faire des jeux de
société et si possible des nouveaux jeux
de temps en temps ça permet d'apprendre
de nouvelles règles de comprendre
différemment d'élaborer des nouvelles
stratégies retenez sajoo et sa garde
votre cerveau jeunes le problème c'est
que parfois avoir un cerveau jeunes ça
suffit pas à éviter les petites
rencontres avec les petits soucis qu'on
a dans la vie de tous les jours
concernant notre mémoire les visages et
j'ai un vrai vrai problème à intégrer
les visages me suivent à des
conversations avec les personnes une
fois que je sais qui est la personne
hier encore on était j'étais un concert
et mes amis de ça parce qu'ils viennent
me prévenir qu'il ya que je risque de
croiser untel et untel il m'aide à
resituer a le visage que je vais me dire
tout à l'heure je connais ben oui tu
connais parce que c'est un tel un tel
appel c'est très cher puisque moi
j'adore les gens vraiment c je ne
retiens pas le prénom des gens c'est une
faute d'attention alors est-ce que je
suis pas assez attentifs pourtant j'ai
l'impression de faire attention aux gens
quand je fais deux nouvelles rencontres
je sais pas pourquoi ça ne rime pas de
très bon pote à moi ont eu un enfant qui
s'appelle un truc qui est un synonyme
avec la mer
gustave pour moi gustave et anatole va
savoir pourquoi
je sais pas je le mets dans le même dans
le même thème j'ai pas y'a rien comme un
thématique de deux mères qui dos et hand
maritime qui me vient est donc pour moi
gustave s'était associé à la mer et
anatole est aussi associée la mer et
donc en fait je me fais fort tout le
temps j'ai un énorme problème
mémoire de physionomie j'étais dans un
an dans une sandwicherie yeux à paris je
j'ai quelqu'un qui rentre j'étais dans
l'est que la personne me regarde avec
insistance mais je coche de la tête et
c'est pour me dire bonjour j bay je me
dirige vers elle sans savoir à qui je
m'adresse je me penche pour lui faire la
bise alors qu'elle commence à me tendre
la main bon donc macha et puis je la
tutoie machin comment tu as qu'est ce tu
fais là et c'est sans savoir à qui je
parle au bout de deux minutes quand vous
savez pas qui vous parler pendant 2006
elle en deux minutes c'est très très
long parce que j'attendais un indice qui
est pas venu et puis il ya son mec qui
était à côté d'elles qui était je me
souviens très bien en costume de velours
petite côte est je ne sais pas pourquoi
je commence un peu de la gueule de son
bec je sais pas pourquoi je voudrais
gueule de son mec et puis au bout d'un
moment ne sachant toujours pas qui je
parle j'ai dit bon ben je vais retourner
dans la queue rejoindre ma femme est là
la dame dit ok il va falloir je reviens
de vouloir docteur parce que j'ai
toujours mal à la gorge et là c'est un
grand moment de trains grandement de
solitude mais intervenants ne sont pas
prosopagnosie que la prosopagnosie c'est
un trouble qui ne permet pas d'encoder
les visages des personnes sans surprise
il s'agit souvent d'un manque
d'attention il existe pourtant une
technique pour retenir le prénom de
visages des personnes je le fais
d'ailleurs moi même sur scène chaque
soir avec le prénom des spectateurs mais
il existe en général des techniques pour
un petit peu tout parfois simplement les
techniques que nous trouvons nous mêmes
dont nous avons besoin c'est franchement
c'est tout simple mais elle est notée
quoi les notée à par seulement au dessus
des notes au moment où tu vas le relire
tu vas tu savate revenir mais si tu ne
note pas pour aller le chercher bon
courage bien j'ai pas besoin d'une liste
sur scène
deux morceaux les autres en ont une
souvent moi je connais mon mon show
parker je sais où je vais souvent c'est
moi qui ai choisi lors des monstres
hectares dont le fait de l'avoir
beaucoup réfléchi je sais pourquoi un
tel moment il ya tellement saut etc j'ai
trouvé une raison donc donc déjà ça ça
m'a aidé à mémoriser et même les
derniers jours avoir la première date le
soir avant de m'endormir je me fais le
déroulement dans ma tête j'ai besoin de
préparer tout le contenu que je vais
lâcher le jour j en direct ou pas
donc j'écris tout à l'ordinateur ensuite
j'ai besoin d informations les plus
importantes je les écris à la main parce
que
rentrent mieux quand je l'écris à la
main tu me dira certainement pourquoi et
ensuite je lis et je demande avant
d'arriver sur le plateau une personne de
mon équipe de me lire l'ensemble de mes
fiches à haute voix pendant que je me
fait maquiller coiffer et en fait à ce
moment-là je connais quasiment presque
tous par coeur et je finis presque les
phrases tu vois deux de chaque
information important quand je dois
jouer une fiction et apprendre à prendre
un rôle je sais qu'il faut que je
mobilise plusieurs sens de tirades que
j'ai du mal à apprendre il faut qu'à
l'intérieur je prenne des mots que je
fasse un petit dessin à côté ce qui
mobilise non seulement ma mémoire
classique pour apprendre ça m'oblige à
réfléchir au type de dessin que je vais
faire à côté pour me souvenir de
certains mots et ça mobilise aussi mon
sens de la créativité puisque je suis
obligé
même ses moteurs je suis obligé de
dessiner donc tout ça fait que à la fin
l'effort que j'ai dû faire pour
mémoriser ma scène est bien rentrée
quelque part dans mon cerveau et que ça
arrive à ressortir et aujourd'hui encore
en jeu quand je joue les fictions et que
je suis devant mon partenaire je revois
quand j'ai vu quand c'est des trucs un
peu compliqué je vois la page s'afficher
devant moi au milieu du visage du
partenaire donc du coup la j'écrivais
toutes les fois les déclinant les trucs
comme ça à savoir je les collais dans
mes toilettes et gelé relisez un
milliard de fois françois loos et quant
à la répétition parfois revenir plein
plein fouet le truc des techniques de
mémorisation elle n existe des dizaines
et je vous en reparlerai à la fin de la
vidéo mais lorsque laurie écrit puis
enregistre puis écoute elle fait
travailler toutes ces mémoires lorsque
michel maille qui a mixé menottes il
porte de la tension et activent le
visuel et kinesthésique y met des
couleurs pour stimuler le cognitif ils
sont obligés de comprendre et de
synthétiser en bref prendre du temps
pour apprendre ça reste la meilleure
manière d'encoder de l'information d'un
autre serbe l'a mnémotechnique en
médecine c'est essentiel pour retenir
les cheveux plus combien douze branches
des nerfs crâniens les douze nerfs
crâniens pour retenir toutes les
branches de la carotide tout ça on
n'avait été des phrases des phrases
toutes faites c'est comme comme mais où
est donc ornicar c'est même un genre de
truc ça permet de soulager le cerveau on
ne se concentre presque plus puisqu'on
sait que ça va ressortir tout seul c'est
tout à fait vrai les techniques que j'ai
pu donner dans mes vidéos ou celles que
j'ai pu mettre à l'intérieur de ce livre
ce sont des béquilles qui permettent de
baliser un petit peu le chemin d'un
souvenir ou d'une information au fur et
à mesure cette information on dit
qu'elle va se sait menti zay en étant
gravé dans l'une des mémoires à long
terme vous l'avez vu dans le titre de
cette partie la mémoire c'est surtout la
seule machine qui permettrait monde de
nous faire voyager dans le temps les
bons moments extra c'est un super luxe
de pouvoir se replonger dans des bons
souvenirs de se rappeler de et oui
aujourd'hui tiens je fais plus ça mais
ça je les fais les guides comme ça c'est
super duke sont partagé ça avec mon
meilleur ami est génial la mémoire aussi
c'est ce qui fait que que l'instant
présent a du sens à ce que tu te réfères
forcément à une multitude d'éléments du
passé pour que l'instant présent et du
sens donc si tu as plus du tout accès à
la mémoire si elle fonctionne plus du
tout l'instant présent n'a plus de sens
je sais que je sais retenir des
partitions de musique par coeur je me
souviens encore des morceaux que j'avais
pris quand j'avais 6 ans par exemple me
souviens de parole de musique me
souviens de certains cours de mon
baccalauréat à l'oral etc mais je
pensais pas que la mémoire olfactive
serait si précises en moi la mémoire
c'est avant tout une extraordinaire
machine à voyager dans le temps elle
permet d'imaginer le futur de comprendre
le présent et de revivre le passé elle
est utile dans notre vie personnelle
mais également pour se construire et
pour construire le collectif d'une
société tout entière en allant à dakar
sur l'île de gorée en prenant en pleine
face la maison des esclaves je sais mais
je suis à la fac et dans médée de
l'histoire ça a été a été effacée ce
truc là sur esclavage enfin merde c'est
le rôle de
des cours d'histoire de faire vivre la
mémoire de deux choses fortes comme ça
et pour pas l'oublier pour le transmed
faut le dire faut pour dire ça existait
pour montrer que ça existait etc il ya
une mise en place de devoir de mémoire
qui est faut se rappeler faut pas
oublier ces horreurs l'a donc avec toute
la le processus mais mort réelle de
faire des commémorations faire des
grands monuments aux morts partout et
c'est pour pas oublier ce qui s'est
passé pour espérer que ça recommence pas
c'est la mémoire c'est subjectif donc
aussi bien individuellement que
collectivement parce que même au niveau
collectif on choisit ce dont on veut se
rappeler que ce soit pour chanter island
la grandeur de la nation ou pour la
regarder regarder son passé de manière
plus critique mais pour éviter de
reproduire des écoles canadiennes
c'est aussi les souvenirs pas forcément
tous utiles dans l'instant présent mais
qui sont hyper importants pour te pour
te construire en fait en tant qu' en
tant que personne
si on cautionnait la version 18 de nous
mêmes qu'on puisse se rappeler de la
version
8 4 pour voir les évolutions et se dire
à l'ail et une amélioration et l'anneau
avant de passer à la suite vais prendre
10 secondes pour remercier les
intervenants de la vidéo les chaînes
youtube de amics m 10 février ma nombre
ils sont en lien de la description je
vous invite à aller les voir tout comme
le dernier livre de laury thilleman que
je vous invite à lire et son instagram
que je vous mets également dans la
description le compte instagram de mike
d'un cas pour le nouveau projet de mike
eric et souvenirs de certains banques où
il raconte 30 ans de vie sur les routes
c'est drôle c'est passionnant et c'est
bien sûr musicale et enfin bien sûr
michel cymes merci à lui d'avoir accepté
de répondre à mes questions un tdah qui
a fait médecine il avait forcément un
regard nous apporter sur le sujet de la
mémoire c'était très intime de leur
demander de parler de leurs souvenirs de
leur mémoire en général c'est une sorte
de mise à nu qu'ils ont fait honnêtement
et sincèrement nous sommes tous égaux
face à la mémoire et je les remercie
vivement d'avoir joué le jeu à ce point
ça m'a été très précieux pour construire
cette vidéo
[Musique]
la vidéo déjà bien assez longue et je
pourrai dédié une chaîne je croyais
youtube entier au sujet de la mémoire
tellement s'érige tellement c'est
passionnant je vous l'avais dit j'ai
écrit un nouveau livre qui vient de
sortir aujourd'hui 12 mai et qui est
sûrement l'une de mes plus grande fierté
c'est mon sixième ligue c'est mon
domaine de prédilection et vous m'avez
souvent demandé pourquoi j'avais jamais
écrit un livre sur la mémoire la raison
elle est simple c'est que je voulais pas
juste un livre de méthode et de
technique je voulais quelque chose de
complet un truc à 360 degrés qui parle
aussi du fonctionnement du cerveau des
astuces de mémorisation appliquée à des
cas concrets des choses utiles mais
aussi qu'ils abordent des traumas les
troubles le déclin cognitif qui parle
des addictions comme du sommeil de
l'alimentation bref exactement le livre
que moi je rêve de voir exister depuis
des années mais ma limite elle est sur
la partie médicale parce que je ne
maîtrise pas assez ça et c'est
naturellement qu'après avoir rencontré
michel cymes sur l'émission antidote
qu'on a décidé de mettre en commun nos
différents savoirs de les vérifier
évidemment et d'en faire un livre
accessible inédit utile et qui couvre
tous les sujets liés à la mémoire et
c'est pour ça que j'en suis très fier
parce que ça fait un espèce de truc très
complet et en même temps factuel et
utile je vais quand même vous montrer le
sommaire simplifiée et allait tenir le
sommaire aussi détaillée de dans le hip
tête va vous le mettre en post prod ce
sera plus clair on a décidé de le couper
en trois gros thème la mémoire comment
ça marche la ville de souvenirs entre
émotion et oublié comment prendre soin
de sa mémoire et quand vous pouvez voir
déjà dans le sommaire simplifier la
plupart des astuces elle s'insère
directement dans les propos contient et
dans les points de vue qu'on développe
par exemple avec la toile du souvenir en
réalité on commence par vraiment le
fonctionnement des neurones après
comment fonctionnent les synapses 5 et
après moi je commençais à intervenir
pour expliquer comment on peut mémoriser
quelque chose durablement dans le temps
etc etc vous avez compris le
fonctionnement donc là il vient de
sortir en france en belgique en suisse
en même temps comme toujours il arrivera
au canada avec un petit décalage quant à
la version audio elle va sortir très
rapidement c'est peut-être même juste
une question de jours et c'est bien moi
qui lis mes parties comme dans mes cinq
livres précédents pour les dédicaces et
comme d'habitude c'est à la fin de mes
spectacles et je vais essayer comme
toujours devenir dans quelques libre et
près de chez vous ça je vous tiendrai au
courant sur mon instagram voilà bah
c'est un beau bébé ça fait ça fait six
ans que je vais écrire mon livre sur la
mémoire ça fait six ans que j'en discute
avec vous quand je vous rencontre en
votant oui j'ai envie de mettre toutes
les astuces dans un livre mais j'ai
envie que ce soit un livre très complet
sur la mémoire il est arrivé j'espère
qu'il vous sera utile dans votre vie pro
dans votre vie perso il n'y a pas d'âge
pour travailler sur sa mémoire et pour
prendre soin de son cerveau donc que
vous soyez jeunes que vous soyez plus
âgés la mémoire c'est vraiment
transversale en fait donc il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de raison de pas s'y
intéresser il n'y a pas de raison de ne
pas servir de son cerveau non plus j'ai
mis tout ce que je savais à ce sujet là
là dedans j'espère vous en ferez un bon
accueil merci à vous c'est grâce à vous
que je peux écrire comme ça des livres à
la base en 2010 elle j'étais parti pour
écrire un bouquin et c'est devenu un
métier à part entière dans ma vie écrire
des livres mon sixième livre c'est un
peu fou c'est pour vous mais c'est grâce
à vous à la base
donc merci du soutien depuis le départ
et puis de la confiance renouvelée à
chaque nouveau livre ça me touche
énormément prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao